Being a professional actor doesn’t always
mean that they can keep a straight face and
why should it?
Acting is a fun profession and they ought
to enjoy themselves while working on set.
Even if they have won numerous acting awards
for their serious roles they should never
shy from having a good time.
Some actors are surprisingly funny and these
comedy chops can be seen in numerous bloopers
from their films.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Movie
Bloopers From Usually Serious Actors.
Naomi Watts in King Kong
The English born actress Naomi Watts has starred
in dramatic roles such films as Mulholland
Drive, 21 Grams and J Edgar.
She’s known as a professional actress on
set but when she was working on Peter Jackson’s
King Kong she had a few breakups during scenes.
Maybe these bloopers are enticed by her co-star
Jack Black or Kong himself but either way
it is fun to see such a serious actress break
up.
Each time she botches her line she added a
much stronger word in its place, making for
hilarious outtakes.
Josh Brolin in Men in Black 3
Josh Brolin moved from being the older brother
in 1985’s The Goonies to playing President
George W. Bush in W and Thanos in numerous
Marvel films.
He’s an Oscar nominated actor for his serious
roles and has co-starred with some of the
greatest.
He was given the chance to let his guard down
but he had to keep his serious face since
he was portraying a younger Tommy Lee Jones
in Men in Black 3.
The only time we get to see Brolin break a
smile is in the outtakes, where he makes funny
voices, let’s off steam and shows his weak
fighting skills.
Emma Watson in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows
When working on Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows the young star, Emma Watson couldn’t
hold it together.
There would be these awkward silences in the
scenes and the actress couldn’t keep it
together.
Giggling take after take, the director added
a system to stop his young cast from laughing.
He would fine them a found after each take
they ruined.
This was all in good fun but Watson did have
the most fines on set.
Billy Bob Thornton in Bad Santa
When making a movie sometimes the director
or writer will have the actor try different
lines in a scene, these lines are usually
jokes and they are trying to find the strongest
one.
All the takes that they don’t use get to
go on the blooper reel and we get a good amount
of laughs from it.
In Bad Santa, Billy Bob Thornton is making
his way out the mall when a security guard
stops him and asks if he might be stealing
something in his baggy pants.
This starts a long line of one-liners from
Thornton, which are of course…bad.
That’s not the Christmas spirit but it is
funny!
Natalie Portman in Your Highness
Natalie Portman is remarkable in her dramatic
roles and even won an Oscar for best actress
in the dark drama Black Swan.
Branching out into comedy, Portman co-starred
in 2011’s Your Highness along side Danny
McBride and James Franco.
Portman had a line that involved calling her
female anatomy a beaver and just couldn’t
get through it.
Take after take she stumbled, even trying
to change the line to better suit her needs.
It’s okay, because she does make it up with
a memorable swimming scene in the film.
Jeremy Renner in Avengers: Age of Ultron
Marvel blooper reels are fan favorites and
everyone can’t wait to buy the Blu-Ray to
see the newest gag reel.
Sometimes the crew actually films a fake scene
to add to the blooper reel like Jeremy Renner
and the Avengers team did for Avengers: Age
of Ultron.
At the cost of his life Quicksiler saves Hawkeye
from a bullet and Hawkeye carries his body
onto a Lifeboat.
In the film Quicksilver lies dead but in the
alternate version he wakes up only to be smothered
to death by Hawkeye.
Hawkeye does not seem to be very grateful.
Bryan Cranston in Total Recall
Since Bryan Cranston starred in five seasons
of Breaking Bad the world has seen his serious
side and we love it.
He’s a pretty cool guy, busting the chops
of fans at Comic-Con or fighting off Godzilla.
He’s been in numerous biopics and has been
awarded countless awards for his dramatic
roles.
During the filming of 2012’s Total Recall
he had some issues remembering the dialogue
“I want him alive for re-implantation”
and goofs up his line time and time again.
Kate Beckinsale in Underworld: Awakening
It’s hard to believe Kate Beckinsale can
do anything wrong but during the filming of
2012’s Underworld: Awakening she has numerous
bloopers.
Fighting Lycan’s is dangerous and hard work
but sometimes you just have to take a break
and dance.
In a slow motion scene Beckinsale kills a
Lycan by firing off a few shots and takes
a misstep causing her to go into a dance.
In real life not even a Lycan would pass up
the opportunity to dance with her.
Malcolm McDowell in Halloween
Ever since 1971 when Malcolm McDowell starred
in Stanley Kubrick's A Clockwork Orange audiences
have known him as a serious actor.
Usually cast a bad guy in 2007’s remake
of the 1978 horror classic, Halloween, he
is being chased by the bad guy, or boogeyman.
In a blooper where Michael Myers breaks in
from a door behind him McDowell goes into
a hilarious improv rant to the masked killer.
Maybe this is why McDowell has been cast in
so many comedies throughout
his career.
Hugh Jackman in Van Helsing
Hugh Jackman is a lot of fun on set and you
can see this just from his outtakes.
During the filming of Van Helsing, the star
not only broke character numerous times to
dance with his co-star or break into laugher
but he also had a hard time in his costume.
That heavy outfit kept getting in his way
and he trips his way through the blooper reel
of the film.
Looks like Jackman needs to practice his stunt
maneuvers before his next film.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any of your favorite serious
actors that made bloopers in their films?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos!
Thanks for watching!